خلينا نحكي شوي عن انت لمحت في الحوار عن
عن الموسيقى والخط انت لك على قبل
الموسيقى يعني تعرف شوي بس فقط سماع
السماع لكن عندي اظن شيء اشتغلت على
الموسيقى لانه عاش معي اكثر من مره عازفين
موسيقيين واخي موسيقي
واللي شابني هو انه الحرف هو موسيقى
عندما جرى تثبيت الحرب جرت تثبيته على
اساس الصوتيات وعلى اساس الحركات مثلا
الثاء والتاء والكذا بمعنى انه الحرف كشكل
وكحجم وكصوت يتوازيه مساحه معينه فمثلا
الحرف الباء هو
انطلق من نقطه من النقطه تحت هو لفظ من
منطقه معينه شو فيها يعني تاء هي نفس
المكان لكن هي من اعلى رفضت النقطه
الزمنين ثلاثه نقاط فاذا هو موسيقى وهو
الموسيقى هي الزمن يعني صوت عبر الزمن
فهذا هذا الشيء بعثت دفعني الى الشغل اكثر
بالتلازم